hola bienvenidos a este especial de
economía hablaremos hoy de impuestos en
américa latina'
y es que los daños económicos que ha
traído la pandemia del covite 19 en la
región ponen a más de uno a preguntarse
cómo los gobiernos van a financiar estos
enormes huecos fiscales el sistema
tributario de la región es bastante
diverso hay países como cuba brasil o
uruguay en donde lo que se recoge en
impuestos como porcentaje del pib es más
alto que en otros en el otro extremo
están los países en donde el peso de los
impuestos en la economía es mucho más
bajo como por ejemplo guatemala
república dominicana y paraguay por eso
saludamos en buenos aires- al experto
tributarista iván sasovsky y le
preguntamos primero nos esperan más
impuestos en los próximos meses
muchas gracias por el contacto realmente
es un gran desafío para las economías de
los países de latinoamérica poder
surfear esta ola que viene como recesión
posterior al confinamiento y a la
situación del cobi
y esto hace que entren en juego
variables que hasta ahora no venían
afectando tanto la circulación de
capitales en nuestra región que es la
competencia de los países para atraer la
inversión extranjera directa y
claramente la creación de nuevos
impuestos en algunos países y no en
otros hace que esa competencia se haga
cada vez más fuerte y que nos
encontremos con situaciones en las que
invertir en un determinado país sea
totalmente distinto desde el punto de
vista económico que hacerlo en otro y en
un país en una situación de recuperación
económica esto puede llegar a ser muy
determinante para el día de mañana
bueno cuáles son esos países que en este
momento ya tienen proyectos para subir o
para bajar impuestos y en cuánto tiempo
podrían estarse dando
hay impuestos que se están pensando y
creando y que tienen que ver con
justamente no el flujo de los negocios
que normalmente ya estaban alcanzados
con tributos sino aquellos nichos de
bases imponibles o de negocios que
pueden llegar a generar algún tipo de
pago extra y que tiene que ver con tomar
el patrimonio y grabarlo
por encima de lo que hasta ahora ya
venían siendo alcanzados por el impuesto
al valor agregado o el impuesto a la
renta en los distintos países de la
región y los países que están trabajando
en la creación de impuestos del
patrimonio hoy por hoy son en primer
término perú que ya tiene un proyecto
que se está discutiendo en el parlamento
por el otro lado chile que también tiene
un proyecto con mucha probabilidad de
que que se termine aprobando y por otro
lado se presentó aquí en la argentina
también la creación de una contribución
que también se calculará sobre el
patrimonio dado que en argentina ya
existía
impuesto al patrimonio que es un
impuesto sobre los bienes al 31 de
diciembre de cada año por lo tanto esto
sería un impuesto extra que se suma a la
carga fiscal en en argentina son los
países que hoy por hoy ya están con
proyectos presentados en los distintos
parlamentos profundizando un poco en
este tema que hablaba del impuesto al
patrimonio hay llamados incluso desde
algunos millonarios a que los impuestos
que deben subir son los de los más
afortunados y no los de la gente más
pobre pero también hay quienes dicen que
eso les incentiva la creación de empleos
como puede equilibrarse esa balanza
sin dudas ese equilibrio es el gran
desafío que tienen los gobiernos de los
distintos países poder alcanzar el
patrimonio sin que esto desincentiva la
inversión porque claramente el empleo
está muy comprometido yo creo que hay
situaciones como por ejemplo en chile en
donde la brecha entre ricos y pobres es
muy amplia y que llevó a que se den
conflictos previos a la pandemia en
donde un impuesto de estas
características puede tener mayores
efectos sin resignar la creación de
empleo la inversión pero después tenemos
situaciones como las de argentina en las
que el patrimonio ya está demasiado
comprometido porque ya paga un impuesto
sobre esta misma base imponible y que
una carga más en un escenario como éste
puede llegar a ser contraproducente
sobre todo para poder salir del
confinamiento argentina tuvo un
confinamiento muy extenso en el tiempo
por lo tanto la actividad económica está
siendo muy resentida
y si uno toma que el impuesto se va a
terminar pagando sobre un patrimonio que
se que se determina el 31 de diciembre
del año anterior claramente todo este
este año de pérdidas no van a computarse
y terminan en muchos casos siendo
perjudiciales para la generación de
empleo futuro bueno y si no son
impuestos al patrimonio también hay
otros como por ejemplo el iva que es uno
de los más fáciles de recaudar pero
también es bastante impopular es posible
que los gobiernos piensen en esta opción
así sea de manera temporal
sí y puede ser una opción que ya se ha
planteado en algunos países de europa
pero la recaudación de impuestos al
valor agregado también terminan siendo
de carácter más recesivo porque
terminará repercutiendo sobre el consumo
cuando el financiamiento por este tipo
de impuestos es de carácter más efectivo
desde el punto de vista de la
recaudación y a su vez me permite poder
ir morigerando a las distintas tasas en
función a la reactividad a la
reactivación económica
esto es un es un elemento fundamental de
la creación de nuevos impuestos a futuro
porque le da al gobierno la posibilidad
de no establecer algo que recién se va a
poder percibir en el largo plazo así que
nos pueden ir regulando lo que van
pasando los meses pero creo que la
competencia hacia la reactivación
económica es la principal herramienta
que tienen los países para poder
recaudar más que justamente tratando de
bajar las tasas pero que en la capacidad
contributiva de la gente no se repercuta
por
en desmedro del consumo bueno y hasta
este momento para tomar decisiones de
esas hay que saber cómo nos está yendo
en materia de recaudo de impuestos en lo
que va corrido del año cuáles son esos
países como más afectados de pronto en
el recaudo tributario
la recaudación de impuestos es
equivalente al nivel de actividad
siempre lo es es decir no hay un
impuesto que pueda compensar las
pérdidas que se acumulan por un freno
tan brusco de la economía entonces los
países que más están afectados por por
esto son aquellos que han tenido
cuarentenas o períodos de confinamiento
más largos donde la argentina está al
frente y en los países en los que menos
se está afectando a estos son en
aquellos que prácticamente no tuvieron
este está restricción en el movimiento
de las personas y de los capitales como
puede ser uruguay
en lo que el cobismo se ha arraigado con
fuerza pero esto es algo muy dinámico
que avanza y retrocede en función de el
nivel de contagios
y la mortalidad del virus en los
distintos países
señor sasovsky hay países que no están
pensando en subir impuestos sino por el
contrario bajarlos o dejarlos quietos en
mexico por ejemplo el presidente anunció
que no iba a ser aumento tributario el
próximo año hay países también que están
pensando en bajarle los impuestos a las
empresas para que generen más empleos
como es este panorama en este momento
cuáles son esos países
a ver la verdad es que la baja de
impuestos como herramienta para la
reactivación económica ha sido probada
en una multiplicidad de países como
irlanda que para la salida de la crisis
del 2008 la baja de impuestos significó
la reactivación de su economía y
llevarla a estar dentro del podio de las
economías mundiales actualmente por lo
tanto esto es muy observado por los
distintos gobiernos de los distintos
países y países como uruguay o colombia
han decidido no gravar a la actividad
privada no restringir con un impuesto
específico a los cargos públicos a
determinados
de sueldos de funcionarios de esa manera
obtener e ir directo sobre un aumento en
la presión fiscal para privados y sin
tener que restringir el consumo creo que
el escenario que se presenta tiene que
tener
una mixtura de ideas
por un lado tratar de restringir el
gasto público en aquellos sectores en
donde sea en gastos superfluos o que
claramente no se verán afectados con
esas bajas y por otro lado la creación
de impuestos que estén alineados con la
creación de incentivos para atraer la
inversión prima por ejemplo garantizar
la seguridad jurídica en los distintos
países o prometer algún tipo de
eximición oa o amnistía fiscal para el
futuro
luego de que toda esta situación de
pandemia haya pasado bueno y si no es
aumento de impuestos que que otras
opciones tienen los gobiernos que no
necesariamente sean tocando el sistema
tributario sino otro tipo de salidas a
esta crisis
a ver hay muy pocas formas de financiar
al estado público en los distintos
países una vez por la creación de
impuestos otro es por el endeudamiento
que pueden tener los países mediante la
emisión de deuda que es una herramienta
que se ha utilizado exitosamente en
paraguay en en perú y bolivia
y por otro lado la emisión monetaria que
obviamente genera su equivalente
inflación por lo tanto creo que el
equilibrio va a estar en el
endeudamiento de los países para
fondearse con capital privado mediante
la emisión de deuda pública y por otro
lado
el fomento de
a la reactivación económica ya sea por
baja de impuestos que implica una mayor
formalización de la economía
latinoamérica tienen un problema
constante a lo largo de todo el
territorio que es que hay un alto grado
de informalidad la economía latina tiene
para crecer muchísimo en la
formalización de la economía quizás con
impuestos más bajos que fomenten la
creación de empleo digamos es decir
ampliar el universo de contribuyentes
con con tasas de impuestos que tiendan a
ser más bajas y de esa manera compensar
lo que se puede llegar a perder
por restricción de la actividad
económica
al señor sasovsky muchas gracias y a
ustedes los invito a que sigan
conectados con nuestra programación en
france 24 y en france 24 punto com
[Música]